I want to tell you about a heavyweight
matchup that's taking place right now
one company on this hand has 650
thousand employees going up against
another company that has 2.2 million
employees this company does two hundred
eighty billion dollars in revenues 2019
this one does five hundred fourteen
billion dollars in revenues one is
Goliath trying to be David one was David
is slowly becoming alive when these two
collapse who wins
we're gonna talk about that today before
I get into the episode makes you stick
around because I'm gonna give you an
infographic that tells you all the data
in one page so if you're sitting down
having a conversation with somebody else
you can have an educated conversation on
whether Amazon is gonna be the Walmart
or if Walmart's gonna beat Amazon so
stick around for that having said that
let's get right into so some data here
at first to measure these two companies
you got Amazon you got Walmart right
Amazon has 650 thousand employees
worldwide walmart has 2.2 million
employees worldwide that's more than
three times Amazon has 75 fulfillment
centers in US Walmart has 42 Amazon's
revenue last year was 281 Walmart did
five hundred and fourteen billion
dollars in revenues last year physical
stores amazon has shy of 600 including
Whole Foods which is about 500 or those
600 Walmart s 11300 stores worldwide
fifty nine hundred and us another forty
seven hundred outside the US ecommerce
business
Amazon's added their two hundred eighty
billion dollars of revenue 141 more than
fifty percent came just from online
e-commerce but for Walmart it's only
twenty two point four billion the number
to keep in mind for Walmart on the
online e-commerce business that's coming
in as the following they did two point
twenty two point four billion last year
in 2019 but they did eleven point five
billion a year before that means they're
doubling their plane offense to get that
number going up Amazon's profits in 2019
was eleven point six billion Walmart's
was six point six seven billion so let
me get this straight
Amazon is doing 281 billion year but
they profiting eleven point six Walmart
did five hundred and fourteen billion
but they profit in half twice the amount
of revenue half the amount of net
profits we'll get to that here in a
minute total products sold Amazon can
sell three hundred and fifty three
million different products Walmart says
35 million different products and in
their physical stores it's only one
hundred and twenty thousand different
products in store it's very important to
keep this number of mind one hundred
twenty thousand products within the
store thirty five million online total
country sold in Amazon's and two hundred
Walmart's and only twenty eight Alexa
Rankin Amazon fourteenth website ranking
Walmart 135 which is not good so here's
the kicker when you're looking at these
two guys these competitors this is
what's taking place Amazon is trying to
be Walmart Walmart is trying to be
Amazon Amazon is looking at Walmart's
and wait a minute we never thought they
were gonna be a competitor but they have
eleven thousand physical stores we don't
have that many
so if Walmart wanted to do immediate
same-day shipping and delivery to you
they can do it I can't do it at Walmart
ninety percent of Americans live within
ten mile radius of Walmart that's
dangerous
a hundred forty million Americans shop
at Walmart every single week that scares
Amazon a little bit right but on the
other side Walmart is sitting there
saying listen I understand we're much
bigger but if we don't get our act
together these guys gonna pass us up in
no time
we better learn what they're doing so
it's almost like a certain level of
envious and saying I wish I had that I
wish I had that so that's why the whole
David versus Goliath thing is taking
place which David is becoming collide
Goliath is becoming David but we'll see
what happened here now look at the
revenues look at the revenues here what
happens between the two of them
Amazon revenue Walmart revenue we're
gonna go back to 2014 in 2014
Amazon's revenue was only eighty nine
billion dollars and watch this
they lost net profits 241 million
dollars this is one that calls on Amazon
investor calls everybody used to say
Jeff what are we going to start seeing
profits what are we gonna start seeing
prophecy would say just trust me just
trust me long term long term long term
next he gets 107 billion
596 million dollars of profits next year
135 2.4 billion profits 177 3 billion
profits 232 10.1 billion dollars in
profits more than three times the year
prior then he goes to 280 point five
eleven point six billion dollars and
profits so now eleven point six billion
dollars and profits it's nearly twice as
much as Walmart now like at Walmart 2014
Walmart's already knew in fallen and
seventy six billion dollars it's not
that big of a difference but their
profits are sixteen billion per year
next year they go to 485 little growth
still 16 billion next year they go to
495 profits goes lower fourteen point
six make sure they go to 44 85 profits
goes lower thirteen point six next year
they go five hundred billion
profits goal or nine point eight and the
last year 2019 they go to five fourteen
but profits goes lower to six point six
revenues going like this profits going
like this what is happening here's
what's taking place they are taking a
play out of their playbook they are
saying listen just be patient we're
gonna get there because they're taking
the money and they're investing into
online e-commerce to try to compete with
these other guys and it's not just
online e-commerce when you see what's
taking place i watch this let's go to
Amazon or Amazon's game this is Amazon's
revenues of where the revenue comes from
remember how we said 281 billion dollars
and I said 141 billion dollars of that
as e-commerce that's the number one
revenue more than 50% but the one part
that we didn't include in this 141
billion is the fact that third-party
sellers for Amazon sell another fifty
three billion dollars on Amazon which if
you include those two to get it's about
one hundred ninety four billion dollars
per year added a two eighty one so keep
that part of my we simply separated it
to say that's Amazon's online stores
right so 53 billion there then you're
going to AWS which is Amazon Web
Services which we'll get into that one
in q4 of 2019 I think it did nine point
six billion and it grew by 35% which is
insane when you hear those numbers we'll
get into what that is I'm a customer of
AWS on two different companies then you
have the subscription which is the prime
19 billion per year 19 billion is just
Prime subscription then you have their
physical store seventeen point one nine
billion a big part of it is Whole Foods
and last but not least is other
fourteen point nine billion whatever
other kind of incomes that they have
coming and now let's go back to AWS
watch this AWS companies that use Amazon
Web Services watch this
Airbnb relies on AWS Netflix is hosted
on AWS Shopify AWS NASA you ever heard
of NASA
she says AWS Adobe GE monstrosity AWS
British Petroleum Amazon Web Services
Department of State Amazon Web Services
Ministry of Justice Amazon Web Services
DBS which is I believe it's the
department Bank of Singapore I believe
it's the Bank of Singapore uses AWS I'm
just giving you some of the customers
these are just there I can give you a
hundred other names that you would most
likely recognize that's what Amazon's
know so what Amazon's do with this this
is allowing them to make money and lose
in other areas it's a cash cow this is
something where a lot of people can do
that has an advantage for them where
they have money coming in from certain
places and they can lose money in other
places they don't care because they have
money coming in it's an advantage that
they have very very big advantage that
they have because of AWS so now these
are the companies that some of the
places that revenue is coming from now
watch this what companies that Amazon
actually own look at this Amazon AWS
wholefoods why they buy Whole Foods
you'll find out why here in a minute why
the about for Whole Foods
I am dB why I am DB again I am DB has to
do with Prime they control IMDB they
control Prime right when I say prime I'm
talking about their what he call her
like the Netflix version of prime that
they have Zappos Amazon owns shoes by
the way Walmart on shoes calm good reads
audible twitch white which future video
gaming think about the way these guys
are thinking right ring you ever seem to
ring the camera ring
Alexa they own Alexa the sound you know
like say hey Alexa can you call this
person hey Alexa when was Winston
Churchill born they own that as well so
calm which so calm is up how do you
describe what soaked out comments it's a
form of what it say it it's an
e-commerce platform like a comparable to
who can we say it's a
similar to like a a Google or an Amazon
in the Middle East it's a form of Amazon
in the Middle East right Prime video
budget by the way so those are some of
the companies they own there's more I'm
just giving you some of them they also
on Prime video right there budget for
prime video of what they want to do
every year is 4.5 billion HBO's is 2
billion dollars and they're not even
trying to watch the movie the other day
honey boy Shia LaBeouf story it was on
prime because I'm prime I was able to
get on like Amazon is everywhere now
watch with Walmart Walmart Walmart on
Sam's Club ok fine it's pretty much
Walmart right
Walmart owns Flipkart Walmart owns
gedcom
what is gedcom one-day budget calm jet
calm was a form of Amazon I think they
pay like 3.3 billion dollars what they
did is they pretty much took all the
employees from gedcom and they hadn't
work on Walmart outcomes website to
become a form of Amazon but it's pretty
much jet calm a similar model to what
Amazon is and then Walmart also bought
vudu.com what vudu.com is like prime
it's like Netflix it's like cooler
because they also want to compete in our
marketplace so sit here watching each
other because they know these guys are
getting close on getting a monopoly and
if they go at this pace it's going to be
tough to compete with a company like
this so stay with me here to give you
some other data so what is this whole
thing taking place America spent last
year 800 billion dollars on groceries
only 2% 2% is online that's why you got
Whole Foods and that's why you got
Walmart trying to get into that market
that 2% they want to get to 10 20 30 40
50 % if that gets to 50 percent that's
four hundred billion dollars that's on
the line you don't think Walmart and
Amazon wants a piece of that here's the
other one all a retail unlike whole
retail whatever we do retail cells in
2019 was roughly five trillion dollars
retail we go buy stuff whole retail you
go to the mall you go to the store five
trillion dollars only 10% of that is
online out of the 10% that's online you
saw 141 is Amazon right five trillion
dollars only 10% is online which is 500
billion dollars this is going to go up
and that 10% is going to go up if the
10% goes to 25% was 25% on five trillion
dollars that's a lot of money right
there
they're trying to compete
for that marketplace both of them
alright and now we know how big Walmart
is with ninety percent of Americans live
within 10-mile radius of a Walmart and
140 million Americans go every week to
Walmart so what are we going with this
what's the point here earlier I told you
David became Goliath Goliath is trying
to become David Goliath is using the
formula of David their revenues are
going higher profits go going lower
because they're reinvesting but here's
what's taking place guess what happens
when you become the biggest the best the
baddest what happens when you become the
biggest the best the baddest and you
start beating people people that have
more experience than you people that are
more educated than you people that were
bigger than you people that you should
have never been what happens when you do
that you start creating enemies and
guess who's craving a lot of enemies our
dear friends at Amazon they're creating
a lot of enemies but guess what's
happening with Amazon creating a lot of
enemies a lot of people are fall in love
in love with Walmart like hoop at like
Google Google is saying hey Amazon we
don't like you we don't like you we
don't we don't want to help Google yeah
we don't want to help Amazon so Google
is saying no problem you're competing
we're gonna help your enemy because an
enemy of an enemy is a friend okay an
enemy of an enemy is a friend and Google
is coming and saying look why don't you
sell some of your products on our
website Google has never done this
before why are they doing this because
they want to empower these guys so
what's gonna be taking place right now
moving forward here's what I can tell
you if you are looking at these two
juggernauts going at it together who's
gonna win this heavyweight matchup a lot
of people are saying 100% Amazon a lot
of people are saying 100% Amazon but
those who are saying 100% Amazon behind
closed doors don't really know what's
going on those behind closed doors who
know what's going on are saying I don't
know I think these guys are pretty crazy
as well they have a lot of capital they
got a lot of money they got a lot of
physical stores people want to go to
stores and buy food right now they don't
want to go tomorrow what if these guys
use their stores as a fulfillment center
yes they have 75 fulfillment centers and
they got 42 but if you really think
about it Walmart's really got 11,000
300 forma fulfillments and I know it's
only a hundred twenty thousand products
that they can stale but it's the hundred
twenty thousand most popular products
that you want to buy right they have
that so what if you can go online and
order your whole your groceries your
milk your food whatever 20 minutes later
deliver to your house what if you could
do that because Walmart's only ten miles
away from you 90% what if they could do
that
that's dangerous over here because these
guys are trying to get more but you know
your buddy call it the drones they're
trying to get all this technology set up
to try to compete with these guys but
it's not a done deal yet for those that
think Amazon's gonna crush them it is
not done deal it look I'm telling you
biggest odds is still on Amazon side I'm
not telling you it's 50/50 odds
absolutely not Amazon has the favor
Amazon currently is Goliath but if
Walmart starts thinking wiring working
innovative being creative like David
like David like these guys were David at
one point this could be a very
interesting very interesting heavyweight
fight taking place the next five 10 15
years now you and I get to witness I
mean you and I get to watch to see see
this taking place we saw Ali Frazier
you know we saw Holyfield Tyson we saw
some good fights Fury Wilder done that
this is a real heavyweight fight because
this is 650,000 juggernaut going against
2.2 million juggernaut so before you say
Amazon's gonna kill everybody know that
a lot of Amazon's enemies behind closed
doors are now helping these guys beat
these guys so we're gonna see what's
gonna happen so I want to hear from you
if you think it's gonna be Amazon
comment below if you think it's gonna be
Walmart comment below and I told you had
a PDF for you the way to get your PDF if
you're in the States send me a text at
three one zero three four zero one one
three two we will send you the PDF three
one zero three four zero one one three
two if you're not in the States click on
a link below subscribe to our newsletter
we'll send you the PDF as well and if
you enjoyed this video I got two other
videos I want you to watch one of the
videos is a speech I give a keynote I
gave titled think like a Grand Master
entrepreneur it tells you moves people
make
I think it's got like a million views in
the span of a couple months if you
haven't watched I highly recommend you
watching this the other one is a video I
did of seeing what's more valuable
Elon Musk or Tesla should you be banking
on Elon Musk or should you be banking on
Tesla and some of the strategies I give
behind closed doors that test that Elon
Musk is doing that maybe not a lot of
people are paying attention to so if you
want to watch this keynote click over
here if you want to watch the Elon Musk
versus Tesla video click over here and
if you haven't subscribed to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
[Music]